Welcome back to the David Pakman show today
I'm going to be speaking with Dr. Eric Topol,
who is founder and director of the Scripps
Research Translational Institute, also a professor
of molecular medicine and executive vice president
at Scripps Research.
It's so great to have you on.
I really appreciate it.
Oh, David, great to be with you.
So let's let's maybe start with vaccination
and kind of center our conversation there.
We have currently two approved vaccines in
the United States under emergency use, authorization
for a coronavirus, the Fizer Bentek vaccine,
as well as the Moderna vaccine.
There are other vaccines that have started
to be approved in other countries, all currently,
correct me if I'm wrong, a platform vaccines.
There has been much made of the short amount
of time it has taken to get these vaccines.
This is something that is merely a function
of the platform, is that right?
It just takes less time to develop a vaccine
under this paradigm.
Well, a few things just to clear up there.
So, yes, the Marnay platform did work very
quickly within days of having the sequence
of the virus that was released from Chinese
scientist in January.
Within days, there was already a template
for an MRI and a vaccine.
But there are some other vaccines besides
the two that you mentioned that have gotten
approval on an emergency basis in other countries
are not.
So, for example, the AstraZeneca is an adenovirus
vector, not an RNA, basically.
And a couple of the Chinese firm and the Russian
Sputnik, these are different.
They're not there.
They're using viral proteins rather than the
mornay, which is basically just giving into
the muscle a message to make spike protein
that's modified instead of the virus.
So it's perfect because you don't have to
risk any virus.
It's just that one component, which is an
excellent target.
And by the way, David, all the vaccines do
have that common thread.
They use the spike protein as the primary
target.
Is there anything what is impure?
I'll say it more broadly.
What is important for the average vaccine
recipient to know in terms of the differences
for them in receiving an MRI and a based vaccine
versus the weakened or dead virus based vaccine.
Right.
So, you know, basically you have two trials
that came out first that were very large,
you know, 44000 with the Fizer by untack and
30000 plus with The Moderna.
They both had 95 percent efficacy.
They both had really good safety profile without
concerns there at least out to two months.
And that should cover most of the concerns
on safety.
So that's kind of a new reference standard
for the other vaccines.
So the AstraZeneca at the main dose that it's
been tested so far had an efficacy of 62 percent
when using a viral vector.
And then others have come in at variable levels,
but they haven't had as large trial experience.
So what you really want is a as a vaccine
gne a person getting a vaccine.
You want to know how high is the efficacy?
How well was it tested?
Was it in really large trials with good follow
up?
These are important concerns because we're
seeing some reduction in threshold for getting
approval because obviously we're in a very
dire situation right now.
You know, when we hear about numbers like
95 percent, as you are talking about, that
would suggest that out of every 20 people
that get the vaccine, one will not develop
sufficient protection against an infection.
Is it possible to know through an antibody
test whether you are in that five percent?
And if so, would it be potentially something
you could do in looking at getting another
vaccine?
If you get the Moderna and you're in the five
percent, can you go and get the Pfizer and
maybe you'll be in the 19 out of 20?
Right, right.
That's a really great question.
And actually, I share your interest in having
a neutralization antibody test.
We don't have one that would tell you for
sure that you're protected.
Yeah, because it isn't 100 percent in the
Maduro trial, which was interesting for severe
infections that would require hospitalization.
It was thirty versus zero.
So it looked like it was 100 percent.
But those are very small numbers.
Yeah, but so one thing is you want to be protected
and and there's not it's not yes or no.
I mean, you want to be protected from.
Most importantly, a severe infections, but
you want to be fully protected.
There's another layer of concern here that
isn't settled, and that is you could get the
virus in your upper airway, particularly your
your nose nasal lining mucosa, and you could
pass it on without this is that term of mucosal
immunity or sterilization immunity.
And so we don't have a full readout on that
yet.
We have some encouraging preliminary data.
So, yes, you're right.
If we could find out the people who didn't
get the ideal response, you could try another
vaccine.
That's right.
And we don't have any, you know, commercial
assay.
To get the answer to your question, David,
we I wish we did, because then you would about
two weeks or a month after you got your second
dose.
Right.
You get a checkpoint.
And then if you weren't high levels of neutralization
antibody, you would get another vaccine.
That would be the ideal scenario.
But nobody's talking about that.
You're the first one that's really brought
that out.
Yeah.
And when you start doing the math, if you
say, well, what what are the odds that if
you've got a room of people, I mean, I think
if I understand the math correctly, if you
have a room of 20 people and you vaccinate
all of them, there is a five percent chance
one has no immunity.
And it is it correct to say there's a two
and a half percent chance that two of those
20 end up with no immunity?
I mean, is the math that simple?
Well, it's not quite that precise.
The reason is, is that, you know, these trials
were really large and we're only talking about
a tiny subset.
Right.
Who were the first ones to cross the line
and get infections.
So the numbers as you get much larger could
be different.
I mean, this is kind of giving you a ballpark.
There were highly significant differences,
of course, but it could turn out to be three
percent or seven percent.
You know, we don't know.
OK, that's another part of this story that's
interesting to point out.
And that is the trials are the ideal experience.
That is they're conducted rigorously with
how the vaccines are given.
But in the real world, they may gotten thawed
out early.
You know, they may not have been cared for.
The actual sterile, the the the glass vials.
Vials.
Yeah.
Thank you.
You know, that were not kept in the deep freeze
or whatever.
So you see, it may be a little different in
the real world.
It usually isn't better.
It's usually a little worse.
Right.
So in terms of I mean, I'll be very transparent.
I think the logistical rollout so far has
been pretty disastrous.
There were promises of 100 million doses in
2020 than promises of 20 million vaccinated.
Today, as we talk, we have about four and
a half million first doses that have been
given out with question marks around how much,
if any, immunity you get from from the first
dose.
It seems it's probably some, but but we don't
really know.
And the vaccine makers are being careful to
say it's not been tested.
At what level do you believe we are going
to start to see and you can answer either
or both deaths and or cases noticeably pulled
down by vaccination?
Right.
Well, it has been a terrible shortfall so
far as you point out, David.
We were expecting at least 20 million people
to have had their first dose in December.
Right.
And we're not even quite at five million yet.
So there is an issue, of course, that the
vaccines have largely been delivered.
That is there's close to 20 million out there
now, but they're just not getting in people's
arms shots now to get this herd immunity,
which is the only way to get to herd immunity,
not through natural infections, through vaccines.
We need to get, you know, at least approximately
70 percent of people.
But the good part in the United States, if
there is a good thing here, is that we let
this virus go with rampant spread.
And so we have at least 60 to 70 million people
who have natural infection induced immune
response.
So you believe that's important now?
So that's about 3x the official cases.
You believe the real infection rate is about
three times the official 20 million or so?
That's right.
It was just published today, actually, just
before we get together and jam a network open
that it's at least three point two X of the
number.
So we had 20 million.
So we're we're about 65 million based on all
the studies.
So the point here is that we could get there
faster.
Go back to your really great question about
if we had a neutralization antibody to the
virus, to the spike protein, if we had that
and we could say rapidly, you have you're
coming into your vaccine or you're in the
line in Q And we tested you in a couple of
minutes later, said, well.
They are good to go.
You're good right now, you don't need the
vaccine.
We need to defer you until we get to 70 percent.
Now, if we could tap into that 60 plus 65
million people, we can get there a lot faster.
But if we don't do that, we're looking at,
you know, third quarter at best.
That means we've got to get to two to three
million vaccine people a day, a day, plus
get them all a second dose.
Now, the JMJ vaccine, which is the Jansons
coming out, you know, perhaps early February,
even later this month, if that clip's that's
a single dose.
So that will make life easier.
Plus, it doesn't require freezing.
That will make logistics easier.
And it will also add to our vaccine supply.
But overall, we're not going to get to population
immunity that we need.
The faster the better, especially with this
new strain, this new be one one seven.
We got to go fast now.
This is a race against a very challenging,
formidable, highly infectious variant.
One last question about the 60 million that
we believe have been infected already.
My understanding is there's still a question
as to the duration and robustness of the immunity
for recovered patients and questions about,
for example, if you had a really mild case,
is how does your degree of immunity compared
to someone who recovered from a more severe
case?
Does it last three months, six months, nine
I. Correct me if I'm wrong, if if reinfection
was really common, we would have way more
examples of it.
If the number is 60 million, that seems clear.
But what do we know about the duration of
natural immunity?
Yeah.
Are you really on this?
This is great.
So the reinfection story, you know, in the
world, we have 35 documented cases by genomics
that you sequenced the virus in the first
infection.
Second, they're very different.
We know that it was an infection.
There's probably considerably more than that.
But if you think about the world number of
infections, it's really low.
Now, that bespeaks the issue, that natural
immune response to an infection is quite good.
OK, so the interesting thing is the vaccine
is what we've written about as superhuman,
that it's even better when I but I mean by
that is the average person now that we've
looked out long enough, has at least eight
or nine months of protection, at least OK,
maybe even years, but at least eight or nine
months.
Now, remember, you pointed out five percent
of people with the vaccine don't have an ideal
response about, let's say, with the natural
response.
It's more than that.
It could be 10 percent, could be 12.
You know, it's it's it's more because vaccine
gets a much higher level of these neutralizing
antibodies, which is the precious response
that drives your protection, no less, you
know, t cells and other, you know, response.
That's part of the protection.
But most of it's the neutralizing antibodies.
So to answer your question, you know, I think
what we're what we can say is if you have
a neutralizing antibody, if it's still there
at good levels, you're good to be deferred.
I mean, you know, you don't need a vaccine
right now.
We need that for other people to get us to
this because we are unfortunately going to
face a vaccine shortage.
Unlike Israel, which is the lead, you know,
the pacesetter.
They're going to have enough vaccines.
They ordered early to have a supply.
They have enough vaccines for everybody.
Yeah, I believe I believe they're at 14 percent
already.
Yeah, actually, that was as of the third as
of today.
They're probably they're going at least one
and a half percent a day.
So they're probably at least 16 percent.
They've they've now have all the vaccines
they need to get everybody vaccinated who's
willing, which is most people, of course,
there, unlike what we have, which is some
hesitancy, resistance, anti vaccines.
But even with our our our issues, our biggest
problem is getting shot in the arm, getting
the second doses at high scale, you know,
like we did in 1947 with smallpox when we
had six 1/2 million people in a few weeks.
We've got to be doing that now every day throughout
the country.
So give us a few bullet points.
There's so much that could be said about the
logistics that could be organized, but give
us a few bullet points about things that should
be done right away.
One anecdotal story, my step mom works in
health care, but not as a direct provider.
She works for a company that that, you know,
in sort of management, I guess you would say.
And she got a call on January 1st saying,
listen, we got vaccines for the first responders.
We have two vaccines left over.
There's no system for us to send these to
a four nurses at a different place.
We just have two vaccines and they're going
to go bad.
Do you want a vaccine?
And she said, sure, that multiplied by a hundred
million, it seems on.
Conceivably chaotic, so like what are the
logistical things that need to happen here,
right?
Well, you know, it is crazy that we're not
just trying to do everything we can to get
vaccines into people.
And so we waste, you know, a lot of shots,
obviously, you know, once they're there thawed,
if they don't get used, they're lost.
And we just don't want any of that to happen.
So we need mass events.
You know, we need an all out effort to get,
you know, a huge number of people every day
throughout the country.
And that will of that, you know, getting stadiums
and big facilities where, you know, just people
on an hourly basis show up and quick, you
know, get their jab or whether it's mobile,
you know, efforts, you know, with with vans
and, you know, whatever it takes.
Obviously, pharmacies could help here, you
know, because they're pretty widely distributed.
So the Walgreens and CBS, they should be part
of the story as well.
But we need, you know, this idea that, you
know, I have high regard for the new administration,
but they're talking about 100 million vaccines
in 100 days, but that's only 50 million people
and 100 days of the new administration.
That's not new.
It sounds so good.
And yet the math of it is still falling very
short.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
So that's just not going to work.
We have to be a whole lot more aggressive.
And I hope that's going to be change.
I hope so.
We've been speaking with Dr. Eric Topol, who
is founder and director of the Scripps Research
Translational Institute, also a professor
of molecular medicine.
Dr. Topol, such a pleasure having you.
And I really appreciate your time.
I know you're very busy.
Well, I'm really impressed how well you're
on this, David.
Are you really?
I didn't think you had a science background,
but it sure looks like you.
I don't I might my my formal training is in
business, if you could have.
No, but I mean, listen, this is it's the issue
of our time, you know, and I for my audience
is saying I must remain informed because you're
a fast learner.
Great to meet you and great to have a conversation.
The David Pakman Show at David Pakman Dotcom.